[Music]
some people figure out hyper loops on
their own in a day or two but most
people find them
frustrating I've played a lot of PO with
a lot of people for a lot of years and
I've created this Resource as my
step-by-step approach and if you really
do each step until you feel like you've
mastered it uh chances are in a couple
weeks you'll be doing hyper
[Music]
Loops to begin we're going to look at a
hyperloop compared to a weave to
understand the rhythm of
each so in a 3B weave if you look at my
orange po my right hand it goes over and
under and back over and under my left
arm a hyperloop adds a circle in the
middle it goes like
this up the middle over under back up
the
middle over under back so to get into
hyper Loops we're going to go once in a
weave over under back middle over under
back over under back up the middle over
under back and we're going learn that
with the right hand and the left hand so
it's a bunch of little steps some of
them seem simple but trust
[Music]
me for our first step here take one po
we're going to start with our
right and we're going to start with a
forward one po buzs saww pretty simple
now if I turn to my left with my whole
body turning the poer now outside of
that hoop I make with my arms if I turn
to the center it's coming up the middle
if I turn to the right it's coming up on
the right just learn to turn back and
forth middle left middle right middle
left middle right now it sounds simple
but the important thing is that it's
really coming from turning your whole
body not by moving your arms in
comparison to your body middle left
middle right middle left middle right
right and really focus on the feeling of
the POI coming up up up up that's also
important same with the left you're
going to make your PO a little bit short
for this by the way up up up up up up up
up up up might sound simple but do it
anyway uh it's going to be
[Music]
important for the steps coming we need
to be able to mimic a weave with only
one hand having a PO cuz we're going to
use the other hand to learn what the
other PO is going to do and that lets us
slow things down so we can start with
the right again it sounds simple but try
it just do a weave and really imagine
you have a PO in the left hand as well
so that you can look at either one I can
look at my right po over under and back
over under and back and with the left
hand I also imagine there's a PO over
under and back over under and back and
again it's good to focus on the ups and
then the same thing with the left hand
having a PO over under back over under
back I can also look at my right hand
and imagine over under back over under
back over under
back so this is going somewhere so just
try and you'll see
[Music]
why now we're going to go from a three
beat weave to mimicking the rhythm of a
hyperloop so again one po right hand
start with your weave over under back
and then you're just going to add the
middle middle over under back middle
over under back back middle and after
the middle you can cut very close to the
fingers of the other hand that's how a
hyperloop will work middle over under
back middle over under back once that's
working alternate between a regular 3
beat weave and the hyperloop and that'll
prep you for learning to go into a
hyperloop so over under back then middle
over under back back to weave over under
back middle over under back and just
keep
alternating when you've done it with
your right same thing
with the left over under back middle
over under
back when you've got that you're
prepping in your body the Rhythm and uh
how and when to go into a hyperloop
[Music]
now we're going to use a POI in the
right hand no PO in the left this is
going to stand in for a PO and we're
going to learn how the right poy wraps
around the
left so again we're going to use our
weave over under back and then we're
going to learn to go through the middle
over under back wrapping around the left
wrist on the way soon that'll be a PO
but we can start really simple we can
start just hold here first thing thing
just learn to do this just a feeling of
going around the wrist could also be two
fingers or one finger right just some
there's something in the way and you let
the PO go around it once that works a
couple times you can go around come to
the left and you're back in your
weave around left and
weave when that works you start in a
weave where you normally cross over
that's where we're going to cut into
your wrist over under
back so over under back through your
wrist over under back over under back
through the
wrist over under
back when that
works do the same thing with the left
and again you can really take your time
at first just learning to do
that then learning to go around whoosh
into your weave
when that works you start with your
weave where you cross over you're going
to go through the fingers then over
under back or around the wrist over
under it's up to you whether to go
around the fingers or the wrist uh some
people find one easier than the other
over under back through the
wrist over under back through the wrist
over under back so you want to do that
till you can repeat it both ways and
then uh we'll
[Music]
proceed now we're going to have a PO in
the left
hand the right hand is standing in for a
poy to learn what the right po will
do so start grab the PO in the middle
and feel you can make a circle up on the
right it's outside of the arms make one
Circle there then one Circle in the
middle and then it releases so circle to
the right the middle and to the left by
the time it's gotten to the left you've
let go so right middle left and
over so from a weave we go over under
and back over we wait for the second we
wait for the the under that's one Circle
two and you really want to wait for the
PO to be coming up close to you and grab
it here where it's close a lot of people
they they try to reach over and grab it
out there you just be patient let it
come to you you go overweight boom
that's where you grab it so in the
beginning you can go over and just grab
it then to the middle then let go pretty
soon you're going okay over and under
and back over and grab through the
middle boom over grab through the middle
boom so there's lot of time when you
grab it it finishes the circle there
then the middle and out over grab middle
out when that works
switch
hands on this side we start outside the
left arm one Circle two Circle three
over one Circle two Circle three over
weight for it one 2 3 one 2 3 over and
one two three over and one
two so when that's working and I when I
mean working I mean effortless I don't
mean you did it once I mean like it's
totally fluid then uh then we'll go to
the next
[Music]
step we're going to start with the left
po again and we're learning how we come
out of a
hyperloop so first we start in the
middle take your right fingers and just
flip the PO
over and by if you don't make it it
hooks so it needs to get over the top
once that works you go over the top you
can just come into your weave boom it
start here flip it over the top into the
weave that's probably won't take long
then you grab your other
Po and it helps to make them a little
bit short for
this and you're going to learn to take
the right po use it to flip the left p
over the top and then it's okay they'll
tangle at the bottom don't worry but at
first it'll go blump and it might make a
knot like that the left po needs to
clear over the top and the right PO is
leading so you want to go jump jump just
like this watch orange po will lead
and they both make it over the top once
that's worked several times you go over
the top cut to the left back to the
weave Over the Top Cut to the left back
to the weave that works you can learn
the same thing the left po will grab the
right po flip it over the top once
that's worked several times you flip it
over cut to the
left and into your weave flip
boom and you can you can mess around and
cheat a bit maybe get it rocking or
coming out to the side um yeah really
play with that one so you get some
success now this one is a little bit
awkward so it doesn't need to be perfect
before you move on but you want to have
enough times having gotten through it um
that you feel like you're beginning to
get how to get out of a hyperloop also
ultimately ult with this one ultim if it
really doesn't work proceed
[Music]
anyway only worry about going in we're
not going to worry about getting out the
other side CU what I see is a lot of
people if they're worrying about getting
out they don't go into it properly so we
just go into a
hyperloop so it's going to be just like
when we did it with the hand chopping
into it there but now you chop it into
it with the PO and then just kind of
open your elbows to make space and it
will naturally come into the middle it
goes one Circle chop you make some space
and a circle or two is enough it then
then it'll kind of BU so you do this
boom and chop and after some tries
you'll get some circles if it really
doesn't work do this a few times boom
right and just come to the middle there
over and boom and you'll get a feeling
for
it and then you do it with po again over
and boom over and
chop after a while you might get more
you might get six circles you can also
go on the other side where the left po
chops into the right
poy and it's okay that's fine it's okay
if it Tinkles up I just want you playing
with getting into the
hyperloop
boom so when you've got success on on
each side coming into the
middle then we're ready to put it all
together and do the whole
[Music]
hyperloop we've gone through a bunch of
steps what I recommend at this point try
to do the whole hyperloop a few times if
it doesn't work go back do the steps a
bit so keep alternating between the
lead-ups and the hyperloop
and then try to put the whole thing
together my right's going to chop into
my
left there it is I chop and I go
out so if you look at my orange POI it
chops up the middle once to the left I'm
right back in my
weave up the
middle back into my weave or the left po
I can chop into the right up the middle
and out and the trick is each po has to
come up my chest once
now with a little practice you could
also have each P come up twice watch
I'll do it from the right I can
go one two one two and out or I could
even go 1 2 3 4 5 six and out but it's
got to be uh odd numbers if it goes
right left right and you try to go out
it Tangles my advice again if it if it
didn't work right now you do the lead
UPS of it try again go back to lead UPS
try again eventually 99% sure that
you'll get it and if you don't make a
video and I'll give you some feedback so
I really hope you have success I hope
you had fun with the process I hope
you're forgiving yourself for anything
that you could forgive yourself for and
uh and that life's okay for you
[Music]